bobby's with us in New York hey Bobby
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
how are you better than I deserve what's
up I just have a good question I've been
doing your plan since December myself
paid off over $23,000 it's kind of a
household name now in my home but
unfortunately having a little issue
trying to educate my daughter with
student loans if she's incurred because
she went to school for a couple years
decided not to go back and now she's
approximately $100,000 in debt with the
student loans and I'm just concerned
because I don't think she's really
taking it seriously like she should Wow
how old is she uh she's 20 okay she live
in your home she lives at home with us
kind of close and nothing she just
thinks that she's still in high school
at certain times is she's really not
taking this the adult way yeah sure
she's got to move out well I've brought
that up but my wife seems to think that
she won't be able to do it and oh yeah
she can do it I noticed you could do it
but the that's the biggest problem is
how would she be able to pay the student
loans and how it should be able to pay
rent and car insurance and fallen or
everything else I don't know if she's
not gonna take your advice I guess she
needs to figure it out put her butt in
the street I wish my mom could be
listening to this right now well when
your mom had done that to you she gave
me the option when I was 19 and I
actually moved out and I did learn from
yes he was telling me yeah you found out
later she was a genius and the older you
got the smarter she yeah
so no I'm serious here here's the thing
no one is going to live under my roof
that I love while I finance their
immature irresponsible behavior it's not
good for them I love my kids too much to
allow them to be crazy and me finance it
right so I want them to find their way
one way or the
the least painful way for your daughter
would be for her to wise up and listen
to her old man because he's a genius
okay I'm serious as a heart attack
because the best thing for this kid
mathematically would be to go okay I'm
going from 13 years old to 33 years old
emotionally because I decided to today
and I'm gonna get industrious and I'm
going to take three jobs and have the
benefit of living at home with no rent
and no food cost and no utility cost and
I'm gonna attack these student loans
with a vengeance because my dad
convinced me that that's the best way
for me to get out of this debt and all
right you know I sit down with her and
reason with her
and tell her that that's what's going to
happen and if it is not going to happen
she's getting she needs to make plans to
move in the next two months because you
are not going to let her stay there and
be a parasite but the other hurdle is
myself my wife because then it causes a
conflict between us well then your wife
needs to understand what's the
definition of an enabler mm-hmm because
your wife is not helping your daughter
she is hurting your daughter because
your daughter is continuing to live in a
delusional State about how life works
because your wife is allowing it and so
she's bringing harm to your daughter so
people say I'm davier that's tough love
no it's love the best thing for this
child is for this child to become an
adult all right
it is the best thing because any you
know any Eagle that does not leave the
nest eventually becomes known as a
turkey you know it just it's a problem
and she's not going anywhere because
she's um her growth is emotion her
emotional growth is stunted yes she's
acting like she was 13 mm-hmm and she's
not a bad kid she's just not she's great
she's just a happy doesn't care about
anything because she doesn't have to
care about anything right and I want you
to help her have some problems I'm
trying to because I think it's gonna be
a big problem and joong-won that when
the loans
kicking in as opposed to one that was
supposed to and made 2025 know what the
next thing it's gonna be if you don't
fix this if you and your wife don't get
on the same page about this the next
thing is your wife's going once you
start paying these loans for her yeah
well I think that's gonna happen - yep
I'm not doing it yeah well that's coming
- so the conflict is coming if your wife
doesn't start to understand what the
best solution is for her daughter and so
it's not a matter of being mean it's a
matter of loving someone enough to help
them - the shortest path out of their
pain and the shortest path is for her to
listen to you and you're moving into the
street if you don't listen to me is a
good way to get somebody's attention
mm-hmm and I I really would do that I
mean firk because I love her you're not
gonna live under my roof and do cocaine
you're not gonna live under my roof and
smoke pot you're not gonna live under my
roof and dot dot dot right you and your
boyfriend aren't staying in the bed
upstairs I ain't happening at my house
okay you know that kind of stuff right
so it's just not happening under my roof
if you're gonna do that kind of crap
you're doing it somewhere else and
you're writing the checks and so we had
a real clear understanding with this as
our kids growing up and actually all the
way through college that we pay for
their college but you're going to behave
and walk in such a way that you have a
job and you're living on a budget and
you're not misbehaving with your
character while you went through school
and you're gonna have a plan to get out
of school in four years and now for
graduating four years
but we weren't mean to our children we
were tough enough on them to let them
feel the realities of life so that it
built muscles in their character but
you're your daughter's has no muscle and
her character right now and she's a good
kid she's got the opportunity to do that
but if you don't get this going in the
right direction she's gonna have a long
decade ahead of her
the time she's 30 she's gonna hate her
life so I hope you guys can turn this
around
hope you and your wife can get on the
same page and love this kid well